have you guys ever had like a proper
real job interview or anything like that
yeah and it was rough well yeah
was yours for like mcdonald's because no
no no no no no i feel like it was
like a real job oh okay so like when i
before i decided to do youtube full-time
yeah uh i was actually still applying
for engineering jobs
right because i was going to do a year
in placement right which is uh in in
i don't know if they do this in
australia you could basically after your
second year in the uk
oh you have an in industry yeah yeah
basically working yeah you get paid to
work and you normally it's normally
those kids do really well in third year
as well because they come into it with a
lot more like like an internship right
practical experience yeah
like kind of like an internship yeah
yeah an internship that actually pays
well and
you normally get a job after it like out
there normally normally they
you get the job offer for that placement
after your like year ends
and some of them might even offer to pay
for the third year and the masters
so it's like it's kind of like no
downside to doing it especially in
engineering right it's really
the hardest part is getting an offer in
the first place it's really hard to get
a good place to take you
yeah i remember i did tests for like
rolls-royce and stuff and they were hard
like they were making every single one
of them it was so annoying
you would apply for it and they'd make
you do this in like an hour and a half
long test that was
hard as [ __ ] yeah and eventually you
just got to the point where you were
like
i've done four of these in one day and
it took all day and
i know i'm not going to get any of them
let's be honest i'm not smart enough to
work in
rolls-royce's jet engine i'm just going
to be honest dude that ain't me
and i i had an interview for one and i i
just remember them asking me questions
and i'm like
[ __ ] i can't even like stomach the lies
i i can't even
i can't even i don't even have the i
thought you didn't even have the
business yeah i care so
little about actually getting this job
that i couldn't even sit there and lie
to the guy yeah
like i wouldn't a normal job interview i
would be like of course
yeah i i never really like worked any
job
like before youtube became a job i mean
like i told the story of how i
tried for mcdonald's and failed and then
i think i did one internship like during
uni but at that point like
youtube was kind of becoming more of a
priority that i knew i probably wasn't
going to go into this field
anyway yeah but like i'm not going to
say the company name but like
last like two years or so i've been
approached by this like
relatively big company like
international that like really wanted me
and that was the first time where i went
into like an actual like proper job
interview yeah but i didn't do one
interview i did 17 interviews holy [ __ ]
not to mention i did some here in japan
and then i also did some
in l.a yeah i can help i did something
in la so like
when i was like staying at aki's place
in vegas
they like flew me out to la just to do
like six more interviews
oh my god well then i had to fly back
and uh at the end of the day
i didn't get the job so i was like
really fun like i'd like to think that
after the 16th interview they were like
you know i don't think so but
let's try one more time and it was like
a different person every time
as well yeah so like but but this is
like a pretty big comment like i'm
pretty sure i'm not allowed to say who
but like it was a pretty big company
yeah and uh
and and it was like it was a company as
well that i was really interested in as
well because it's like oh like if
youtube falls through
this is a perfect place to work yeah
like hell yeah like this is my plan b
and so i was genuinely excited to be
like maybe i might get this job i don't
know and then
yeah but yeah it was just [ __ ] but i
think that just made it so much more
stressful
yeah i remember oh sorry because it was
like because i was genuinely interested
but it's like
how do i like tell that to the person
without sending like an absolute kiss
ass
you know like you actually do want to
work it's like it's like yes i love
everything you do of course i want to
work for you if you've got that job
would you have quit youtube
hard to say wow i'd say now the with the
place you're at on youtube i remember
every person in their youtube careers
thought maybe i'll get a proper job
because i don't know when this will fall
yeah right
it was it was at that point where i was
like i'll give myself a little bit
there's a lot of anxiety and a lot of
uh what's the word like you you don't
trust it
yeah like you don't think you think it's
temporary yeah even though you know it's
not
yeah there's always that gut feeling and
then i think i can understand sometimes
why
you know some people youtubers want to
move on and want to do something else
yeah i understand that
i don't have that interest right now and
i don't want to move on cause i'm really
enjoying it
but you know i could i can i'm starting
to understand after doing this for like
five years
i can understand the mindset of why
someone wouldn't want to be in that
coin flip every day is like well let's
see if i've got a job today yeah
right yeah it is kind of like it is
really stressful to do and i think that
i've just become used to it
but if you put someone in this situation
overnight i feel like it's one of those
things where it's like oh they wouldn't
be able to handle it
maybe not handle it but it would
definitely it would definitely wear on
you i think
yeah yeah absolutely going back to job
interviews i do have like a story of
like my very first i'd say
real job interview because you know i
i've had job interviews for like co-op
and
like call centers and stuff we're
talking like they just they just want to
make sure you're not a [ __ ] criminal
exactly
all you have to do is just be a
competent person and somehow joey can
couldn't even be that for mcdonald's
interview but
that's that's a different story but like
we're talking actual like big boy
companies okay
you're here for a specific skill set so
this was like before i got my job at the
bbc so
as you do as a graduate you apply to
about 10 [ __ ]
10 million different companies you just
hope one of them sticks yeah so
one uh one company that actually um
called me back for an interview was a
missile company
so i would basically be kind of like
like
yeah yeah like one of them what other
missiles are there joey
i don't know it just sounded really
weird it's like a company that makes
missiles like what sound missiles make
so yeah what do you do yeah i designed
get down the missiles
but yeah it was a it was a proper
missile company and i was
applying to be like a systems engineer
to like design and make missiles
so like obviously i go in the i go in
the interview and
i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] nailing this
interview okay i i i can't i can't
remember i can't remember how it is like
like the interview was split up into two
different segments
like there was the one where like they
like into your like personality and i
don't know what i can't remember what
that's called no there's a technical
term
oh yeah yeah yeah there's there's
there's one where they're like they you
know
they grill you about you know what why
why do you why do you think you'd be a
good fit for this company
you say you're a [ __ ] team player
yeah you you're a perfectionist to uh
what i'm going to do what one of my
weaknesses oh well you know i just uh
i'm
i just i'm i love money i love money i i
am a perfectionist and you can't [ __ ]
say look i just need money
and i need to pay off my [ __ ] student
loan why are you asking me questions
that you know the [ __ ] answer to
okay so but like i i breeze through that
and i know i know
they've i know i'm doing a good [ __ ]
job right and then i get to the
technical interview
and the technical interview i actually
prepared for this right because
you know i'm working for a [ __ ] i'm
applying to be a [ __ ]
missile designer so i should probably
know the basics of how a missile works
right and sure enough
i get to the technical interview and
they ask me um so can you explain
the broad basics about how a missile
works
right and so they go
no so um i've mentioned this before but
my degree is in electronic and
electrical engineering so i was
um so basically this this was this was
going to be a breeze for you i know how
a missile works so
i've done my research yeah yeah yeah and
so
um i start so there's two interviewers
there's one
older serious guy and then there's one
like younger not exactly a grad graduate
he's been there a few years but he's
like
he's like at the time he was like late
20s early 30s
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly so i start
like i start
explaining how this missile works so
there's like a white board and like so i
draw
i draw the missile right and and i'm
like i'm like explaining explaining
explaining everything i'm like yeah
together this system does this this
isn't on this
and so my final year degree
project uh my thesis story was on like
object
real-time object tracking and everything
like that so perfect perfect for what i
need to
explain here so i start explaining how
this missile
like tracks different objects so i draw
this rectangle
and i label that target and then i draw
a dotted line
from the target to like this missile
that i've drawn
right and so i started explaining okay
this is how the tracking system works
and the tracking system is in the front
of this missile and so i cordoned off
the front of this missile
right and i'm [ __ ] getting into this
i'm like okay so this is this is how
this is how my experience with my
tracking degree can can like
help with how i can explain like how i'm
missing myself right yeah i'm [ __ ]
telling myself
i'm getting into it and then i look over
and then
like the older serious guy was just like
hmm yes very in sweat and then the
younger guy
was like trying to hold his laughter he
was just like
oh no what did you draw on the rocket
gone
and and and then and then i look over
i'm like and i'm thinking to myself like
why are you laughing at what i'm doing
i'm on i'm killing this
i'm [ __ ] killing this my career is on
the line here i just want to get a job
what he
what could you possibly be laughing at
and then i look at what i've drawn
i've drawn a penis how how did you draw
a piece
i've drawn a big girthy penis
pissing on a rectangle and how
how did you do that i've actually i've
actually got a picture right
i've i've got to show you i was really
hoping this story's climax would be
about a penis yeah
i was thinking when he was like
[Music]
i didn't realize how much it looked like
a [ __ ] penis
until that's
as soon as i saw that right i knew i
failed not because not because i was
doing a bad job
but you know when you're in the zone and
like
and like there's no there's nothing that
could take me out of the zone
knowing that i've just drawn a [ __ ]
penis into in front of two examinees
and then after that i just start
stumbling and i forget everything i
prepared
all right right you failed that time
yeah yeah
you didn't get it i didn't get it
they specifically said that i did super
super well on my like the personality
side of things
but uh the technical side was uh lacking
yeah
until you draw a phallic object on the
whiteboard